Speaker 1: . Let's continue our coverage of
CPAC.
Next, I want to look at a Donald Trump junior
speech, and then we're going to look at some
interviews with attendees.
And I have some bigger picture thoughts about
CPAC, which I'll tell you in a moment.
Earlier in the weekend, Donald Trump Jr. spoke
and everything from even just how he was introduced
to what he said to the strange applause lines,
to an interview he gave.
It's all really horrifying stuff.
But in the straw poll that was conducted and
announced at the end of CPAC, other than Donald
Trump, Don Jr. was actually, I believe, third
in terms of twenty twenty four presidential
candidates.
This is not a guy who should be ignored.
This is a guy who has a lot of the same terrible
instincts of Donald Trump, but is far more
competent and a far better speaker.
So let's get right into it.
Here is Don Jr. being introduced, introduced
by his girlfriend, former Fox News host Kimberly
Guilfoyle.
It's all like just cult of personality type
stuff.
Speaker 4: He's showing me and welcoming a
true warrior and the embodiment of that first
Unidentified: moment, Donald Trump Junior.
Speaker 1: Weird, skip.
Yeah, so you get the idea, but just complete
cult of personality.
There's a very kind of totalitarian, authoritarian,
you know, cult stuff that continues to happen
at these events.
And I mean, just to give you a sense of it
here in this next clip, you'll sort of hear
a crowd member yell Trump won during Junior's
speech and he lets them cheer for a full minute.
I mean, it's it's a level of sort of like
deistic idolatry that should scare all of
us because of how divorced from reality it
is that they're like.
They're just cheering for Trump, one that's
a defiant and an inspirational thing to say
at this event.
Yeah, so you get the idea of what cheering
for guys sounds like, then there's a really
strange moment where he seemed to lose his
ability to speak coherently for a moment,
said something weird about Texas and then
kind of looked around.
I still don't understand this moment, but
take a listen to it.
Speaker 3: You know, Texas has always led
the charge.
Well, till about like a couple of months ago,
and then Austin sort of took over like, I
don't know, guys like Texas was leading the
charge.
You're still tough.
Twenty five.
We got to work on that stuff because most
people have lost their minds.
Huh?
Right.
Speaker 1: So very strange, you know, you
may want to save the anti-tax, this material
for when CPAC is in a state other than Texas,
Don.
I don't know.
I'm not an expert on this type of thing, but
a very, very strange moment.
And then things just continue to get weird.
I don't know.
Let's just even take a look at this next one.
I'm not even sure what we're going to see
here.
Speaker 3: Can't allow it to happen.
We need to push back.
Speaker 1: The.
Oh, OK, so there's the Trump one thing and
then let's skip ahead when he goes back to
speaking, I guess.
Speaker 3: He's the most popular president
ever.
He's significantly more popular than Barack
Obama was in 08, especially in the inner cities,
because he has a track record of not being
racist.
His son definitely didn't drop, let's say,
words that I don't even want to use abbreviations
for with letters in them.
Speaker 1: So then he really goes into the
Hunter Biden stuff.
And I've been saying for a while, this is
a party that they're off of issues.
They're not doing any political issue stuff
anymore.
It's stop communism, which you'll see in the
interviews with the with the attendees.
It stop Joe Biden.
Joe Biden has dementia.
They're undoing everything Trump did and they're
redoing things Obama did.
And then he really goes in on Hunter Biden
and calls him a piece of garbage.
Speaker 3: I say that, oh, you're making fun
of people with addiction.
Like, oh, let's just talk about this for a
second.
I totally understand addiction.
It's terrible.
We all know people that have suffered from
it.
It doesn't absolve you from being a total
piece of garbage in every other aspect of
your life.
Speaker 1: This used to be an event.
At which they did talk about policy policy,
I didn't agree with policy I found to be completely
immoral and disgusting, but the president's
son is a piece of trash is now what they're
doing.
Here's one last clip.
Here's Don Jr. being interviewed before or
after his speech.
And it's very clear he is going to be as involved
as Trump in 22
Speaker 3: because I'm going to be very involved.
The reality is, you know, I'm the father of
five young kids.
I'm a patriotic American.
I love this country.
And I look at what's going on and someone
has to push back.
You know, there's not many people that have
sort of the privilege of having a big platform.
There's not many people who have a big platform
that are actually willing to use it to sort
of go against the mainstream narrative.
I think the facts are on my side and it's
about all we have to have.
So I'm happy to do it.
It's an
Speaker 1: honor.
I'm telling you guys, this is a guy who, if
he gets the oxygen Trump got in, you know,
10 years as as of right now, we have a country
that would elect Don Jr. president and he's
far more competent than Donald Trump.
I think the left should actually be scared
because the right has proven they they will
elect anybody.
And if Trump can get elected, I think Don
Jr. can get elected as well.
It's scary stuff.
Let's now talk about the Trump supporters.